[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact on August in
2018 NASA launched one of its most
daring space operations it's called the
Parkers Solar Probe better known as the
PSP named after solar astronomer Eugene
Parker it's a robotic spacecraft with a
mission of entering the outer corona of
the Sun to make it on observations and
record data regarding the solar wind to
reach the sun's atmosphere without being
sucked in by the Stars massive gravity
the PSP will use the gravity of Venus to
swing it within 3.8 million miles of the
sun's surface now that may not seem like
it's very close but consider we're 93
million miles from the Sun and it then
will plunge it through the Stars
atmosphere and back out again over a
period of seven years the craft will
make seven flybys gathering data as it
streaks around the blazing surface of
the Sun at catch this 43,000 miles an
hour that's faster than any man-made
vehicle has ever traveled to survive the
blistering solar temperatures the
spacecraft and instruments will be
protected from the sun's searing heat by
a five inch thick carbon composite seal
designed to withstand temperatures
outside the spacecraft hot enough to
melt steel this bold mission is the
culmination of 60 years of work
commenced by 92 year old professor
Eugene Parker who was able to be present
for the liftoff becoming the first
person to see the launch of a mission
named in his honor while most of life on
Earth comes from the Sun the Bible
speaks about another star that should be
given very careful study stay where
those friends were going to learn more
or on this edition a Bible answers live
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 7 to 97
we're also streaming this if you ever
curious about what the program looks
like in addition to what it sounds like
it's on Facebook at amazing facts face
book page or the Doug Batchelor Facebook
page my name is Doug Batchelor and my
name is Sean Ross good evening frames
and passive ugh let's start the program
with prayer dear father we thank you
that we had this opportunity once again
to open up your word and study together
and we do ask for the Holy Spirit to
come and guide us as we search the
Scriptures Francis so commit our time
into your keeping in jesus name amen
amen
hope acid are you open the program we're
talking about a rather interesting
mission and that is to go as close to
the Sun as one day or without being
burnt up well eventually as you
mentioned at some point this spacecraft
will probably be sucked in to the
gravitational pull of the Sun and
eventually just burn out but until then
possibly seven trips around the Sun and
gathering as much information as it can
yeah taking all kinds of measurements
and probing and seeing what they could
find out about you know the solar wind
and probably gamma
and all kinds of things about the Sun
they don't understand because they can't
get really close enough you know when
you think about it though this is going
to be man's really first and only
opportunity to visit a star because the
Sun is the only star really within our
reach all the other stars I think the
closest stars are either alpha Proxima
or Alpha Centauri and they're what they
call four light-years away
meaning if you travel 186,000 miles a
second now this is craft actually the
PSP is gonna go 0.6% the speed of light
at one point that's pretty quick
but to go the speed of light 186,000
miles per second you have to go four
years at that speed to get to the
nearest star and then the time it would
take to send data back I'll forget about
it yes so in this life you know when
when we're in our glorified bodies we
expect to go from star to star but in
this life this may be the only man-made
mission to a star when you think about
it but it makes me think of a verse in
the Bible pastor Ross where you read in
Revelation the last chapter in the Bible
Jesus says in revelation 22:16 I Jesus
have sent my angel to testify to you
about these things for the churches I am
the root in descendant of David the
bright and morning star
so the real you know people say they
want to worship a star or idolize a
movie star but they're the real bright
and Morning Star is the only star that
should be worshipped or idolized and
that's a Jesus if people would just know
more about this incredible personality
that has changed history and not just
the personality a divine person I should
say that has transformed history and
we'd like to introduce people that are
listening to know him better I was
talking to a friend that just returned
from China and about a trip we made to
China a few years ago and I was shocked
when I I talked to one of our drivers
there it's mentioned Jesus he said well
who's Jesus there are so many atheist
people that never even heard his name
and these are educated people it was
mind-boggling to me that someone could
live
in the world where the largest religion
of the world they were oblivious to who
Jesus was
there's people in North America that
know about churches they hear Jesus name
maybe ingest or in cursing but they
really don't know who he is and we have
a special offer tonight if you'd like to
get to know him better it is a book that
will be happy to sing to anyone who
calls an ass the book is called down
from his glory and we'll send this to
anyone who calls and asks the number to
call he's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and again just ask
for the book called down from his glory
and we have happy to send it out to
anyone who calls 883 five six seven four
seven and we're gonna go to the phone
lines our first caller that we had this
evening is Stacey listening from Atlanta
Stacey welcome to the program
hi thank you very much hi pastor hi
Pastor John hi I have two questions for
you
hi the first question is from Daniel
12:2 many of them that sleep in the dust
will awake some to everlasting life and
some to everlasting shame why many and
why not all of them aren't all going to
be resurrected one two one
well I think Daniels making it clear
there are two resurrections and I know
you're saying well when when the Lord
comes back aren't all those that are
raised at the second coming dead in
Christ is that what you're implying why
not all it says and many of them at
least in the desc will awake and one
will go some will go to everlasting life
and some to shame and everlasting
contempt
why doesn't Daniel say and all of them
that sleep in the dust shall awake why
is it many of them why is there somebody
missing yeah two reasons there you know
of course there are two separate
resurrections one resurrection takes
place at the end of the 1,000 years
jesus said the hour is coming in which
all that are in the graves will hear his
voice and come forth they that have done
good the resurrection of life they that
have done evil the resurrection of
damnation do you want to find out when
that resurrection is you look in
Revelation 20 it says the dead in Christ
rise first blessed and holy is he that
has part in the first resurrection the
rest of the Dead lived not again until
the thousand years are finished we have
the dead in Christ are the Blessed and
holy
the dead must be the wicked for lost now
we have a study guide that explains
those two resurrections and I think it's
a guide on the Millennium if I'm not
mistaken you didn't okay I bet it my
next question for you is I noticed that
God changed Abraham Abram to Abraham
James Israel Saul to Paul why do some
people get new name now I forget the
verse pastor Ross but in Revelation
doesn't it say that I will give you a
stone is that in part of the message to
the seven churches like if you stone
with a new name that no man knows
eventuated and so I do think that in the
kingdom he gave Peter a new name Peter's
name he called Simon he called Peter and
John and James he called Bo energy sons
of thunder so I do think that we will
all get a new name in the kingdom okay
and pastor us he's looking up that verse
it's in Revelation 2 or 3 revelation 3 I
believe it is and it's talked about a
white stone actually it's Revelation
chapter 2 verse 17 okay yep and it says
this I will give him a white stone and
on the stone a new name written yeah so
all the believers end up getting a new
name to go along with our new bodies
that's great
great news well thank you very much hey
thank you so much Stacy appreciate your
question next caller that we have is
Sandy listening from Illinois sandy
welcome to the program hi pastor Doug
and Pastor John I'm just trying to get
my theology rock solid in the Bible
there's the ironic blessing which is
numbers chapter 6 like verses 24 through
26 you know the Lord bless thee and make
it very shy nap on me and I'm in a
prayer group that I love and it's a huge
blessing but I just want to make sure
because I it's in Hebrew somewhere in
the vicinity of chapter 7 through 9
where Jesus is now in the most holy in
the heavenly sanctuary after the order
of Melchizedek and I just want to know
is it okay to still claim the ironic
blessing or what are your thoughts oh
absolutely the the blessing that God
gave for the priests to pronounce upon
the people is a blessing that
any spiritual leader can pronounce on
God's people this is one that we all
seek and by the way let me just read
through it because it's beautiful it
applies and this is one Jesus you would
certainly want the the Melchizedek
Priesthood in Jesus to say this the Lord
bless you and keep you the Lord make his
face to shine upon you and be gracious
to you the Lord lift up the light of his
countenance upon you and give you peace
and he says so you will put my name on
the children of Israel and I will bless
them so it was just a way for the
leaders spiritual leaders to remind the
people that their blessings came from
God the God of the Bible okay thank you
so sure that woman that would be that
would be something that be appropriate
for a pastor to declare we often say
that or derivative of that and as a
benediction in our services okay so it's
not going backwards it's not going into
the holy place out of the most holy
place
no that was my concern okay okay
thank you thank you bye-bye all right
you're welcome you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time call us at
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm next one of the
behaviors Chris listening from Florida
Chris welcome to the program yes thank
you very much and my question is from
book of anglers yes I was 11 actually 11
and 12
there is no 11 or 12 in Amos yes what
chapter in Amos Amos only goes to
chapter 9 I'm ok 8 8 11 and 1208 M is
chapter 8 verse 11 and 12 okay and you
want me to read that yes no I don't I
read that for people listening because a
lot of folks are driving behold the days
are coming says the Lord God that I will
send a famine in the land not a famine
of bread or a thirst for water but of
hearing the words of the Lord and they
all wander from sea to sea and from
North even to east and they'll run to
and fro to seek the word of the Lord and
not find it so you wondering what does
that mean and was that prophecy did it
come true no better than the Senate so
all of the nations well I think that
there's a famine for the Word of God
even today you know it's possible for
people to have Bibles in every home and
if they're not reading them or
understanding what they're reading they
can be starving spiritually and I
frankly think there's a famine for the
Word of God in our country right now but
this happened also several times in the
past with Israel where they were
neglecting the word of the Lord or they
didn't understand it and I think it also
has a future application we know that
according to Daniel chapter 12 the time
comes where probation closes for the
human race revelation 22 speaks of a
time when Jesus says he that is holy let
him be holy still he that is filthy let
him be filthy still this takes place
just before the second coming of Christ
the seven last plagues are poured out
but during that time period they won't
be evangelism taking place people would
seek perhaps for the word and they won't
find it because probation is closed and
the Bible says it's the goodness of God
that leads us to repentance
hmm yeah so it could have a future
application very good but I'm thinking
about also about the missionaries are
those missions in Africa and everywhere
yeah well you know there are people
hungry for the Word of God right now and
when they seek they find this prophecy
is talking about a time where they're
gonna seek it they won't find it and
it's interesting in Amos 2 8:12 he
doesn't say usually they say north and
south or east and west but here in this
prophecy says they'll go north and east
and not find it which is unusual so it's
almost like you know they're they're
going to the Eastern religions or some
of the northern religions are I don't
know but it's different but they're
they're not finding what they're looking
for
I'll famine for the word of God very
important hey thank you so much we
appreciate your question Chris and who
do we have next best Ross we've got
Andrew listening from Tennessee
let's see Andrew welcome to the program
well pastor doesn't Pastor Ross have a
question I was watching at YouTube
I guess program day regarding the state
of the Dead and somebody was somebody
was advocating stating today that I
don't agree with and they used
revelation 6:9 311 I was just gonna read
that for people so we they have the
context before we answer it yes and
revelation 6 9 to 11 it says and when he
had opened the fifth seal I saw under
the altar the souls of them that were
slain for the word of God and for the
testimony which they held and they cried
with a loud voice saying how long O Lord
holy and true dost thou not judge and
avenge our blood on them that dwell on
the earth and white robes were given
unto every one of them and it was said
to them that they should rest yet for a
little season until their fellow
servants and their brethren that should
be killed as they were should be
fulfilled so people are gonna say well
here you've got these conscious souls
under the altar so they're not really
sleeping this verse is obviously it's
using symbolic language who would want
to die and be a soul under the altar
crying
and the very fact that they here told
the rest a little longer but it would
say yeah when someone dies they do rest
until a resurrection but this is all
speaking in spiritual terms of course
Revelation is a symbolic book and this
is one of the seals that are open this
is the first seal and it's really
describing a time of terrible
persecution that came upon the church
during that time there were probably
many believers that cried out and said
Lord how long are you gonna allow this
persecution and the answer came back yet
a little while longer
nevertheless the assurance was given to
them when it says a white robe will be
given to each of them the assurance of
eternal life if they faithful to God
nevertheless he was to give them Grace
and strength to endure that time of
testing that's actually a prophetic time
period that we find in several places in
Revelation talks about a 1260 years of
severe persecution that came against the
followers of God okay so so if that's
embolic and I could I do understand that
certain certain things smoking and
prophecy of symbolic but how how am I
supposed to tell the difference and how
do I explain to them this is symbolic
and this is actually speaking of
something well comparing Scripture with
Scripture when the Bible says in Genesis
that the blood of Abel cried to the Lord
from the ground you'd have to ask him is
that blood literally crying or is he
using figurative language they're saying
that justice was crying out for for
vengeance or for fairness after Cain
killed Abel so when these souls under
the altar they're crying out it's
talking about they've been killed for
their faith and it's basically justice
is crying out to be meted to their
adversaries it's the same thing as and
you know even when you read in Hebrews
it speaks better things than the blood
of Abel blood doesn't speak it's talking
again about crying out for vengeance or
justice or retribution on those who had
been persecuting God's people
so yeah just comparing Scripture
Scripture because you take this
literally I mean who would want to die
and be a soul all confined under an
altar crying
and then because they cry they're given
robes and then they they're told to go
back to sleep I mean come on yeah that's
I think people that say this is proof
that you're conscious after death is
it's a pretty weak argument thank you so
much appreciate it thank you appreciate
it Andrew next caller that we have is
Shayla listening in Sacramento Shayla
welcome to the program Shailesh I'll are
you there she may have her mute on oh hi
in your question my question
politics are questions if should
Christians be involved in politics is
that what you're wondering
yes well it depends you know there's a
lot of things that happen in politics
that the Christians could easily get
distracted with you know we are
technically citizens of a heavenly
country but you know sometimes in our
government there have been political
issues where Christians fought against
slavery and some might have said well
that's a political issue well it was but
it was also a moral issue there are
Christians who are fighting against
abortion well some say that's political
but it's also a moral issue there are
some political issues that Christians
should take a moral stand on I just want
I think that Christians should be
careful not to get too politically
engaged and you know you got Christians
that are Republicans independent and
Democrats they all love Jesus but they
fall on different lines of certain tax
issues or Public relief issues they
don't want to be arguing over those
things
so are there Christian politicians yeah
Daniel worked for the king and he was a
believer and Joseph worked for the King
and he was a believer and Mordecai
worked for the king in a political
office and he was a believer so there
have definitely been some Christians
that had to operate in the political
world King David it's another one so a
good question Shailja but Christians
shouldn't get too involved in that get
distracted with it
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 885 six seven four seven once again
that's 800 eight three five six seven
four seven four life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore com next
one of their behalf is Debra listening
in Burbank I heard your voice and I'm
hearing my name Debra why we're here
some feedback here you got your radio on
I know because my car's going through my
car speakers oh alright and your
question sorry my question is about this
guy just walked up to me and started
saying that the Bible proves that the
earth is flat and that there's a man
that has a YouTube channel and YouTube's
trying to shut him down there's a
conspiracy trying to shut it down
because he's telling everybody in you
know like so this is somebody that
believes the earth is flat yeah and he
says he's a born-again Christian he
started to tell me and I told him it
wasn't biggle yeah I know it's not
biblical the earth doesn't say the world
is flat Bible actually talks about the
circle of the earth just because you
might find in the Bible where it talks
about the Sun rising do we really
believe that the Sun rises or is the
earth going around the Sun you know the
people that take that point of view they
also don't believe that's same group
I've seen some of their stuff and it's
it's laughable if if so many people
didn't believe it it would be funny but
it's sad because people believe it they
believe that the whole moon landing was
staged by Hollywood that no one ever
went to the moon and they think that
they think that the pilots that are
flying around the globe are deliberately
conspiring with mapmakers to deceive
everybody into thinking the world is
round and my question is what do they
have to gain by that why would they have
this epic conspiracy to make you think
the world is a sphere when it's really
flat and what happens if you sailed off
the end of the earth do you think I mean
it's it's a craziest thing in the world
right and then also I did a little
research myself and
what I saw was that is like a resurgence
of an old story that originated trying
to disprove the Bible in the first place
yeah well you know I think I found it
funny that a born-again Christian would
would you know come up with that this
I've met some sincere people that have
been deceived by this but you just got a
pray form it's really sad that an
intelligent person would think that the
earth is flat right I'm a pilot and I
pastor Ross and I've been all around the
world he's from South Africa and you you
can see you get high enough and far
enough away and you can see the circle
of the earth when you're at 40,000 feet
just looking out your windows anyway
it's too bad that there are some people
that they think the moon landing was all
staged in Hollywood anyway all right hey
thanks so much for your question yeah I
just got to pray for them by the way
there's a I saw a YouTube video where a
Hollywood producer
he went frame by frame through the moon
landing and he said that the idea that
that was staged in Hollywood is totally
bogus because the technology to do the
special effects they're claiming that
we're done did not exist back then and
this guy's very believable anyway that
someone I was surprised he took the time
to debunk it but anyway hey thanks so
much Debra I'm glad you mentioned that
because there's other sincere people out
there that are gonna run into this
bamboozling goo furry all right our next
caller that we have is Dan listening
from Washington Dan welcome to the
program hi hey Dan thanks for calling
yeah I listen to you all the times
about two and three times a day oh we
got to get two in a support group I need
a support group if I can't find one
around here i I there's a church I'd
like to go to but they want to invite
the tree a Christmas tree and when I
asked them about it they said that to
help bring people into the church so I
said well if it's not in the Bible and
anymore it's turned 180 from what it
meant you know what what they were
trying related to with the birth of
Christ you know in the manger and all
that and now their time take the dot
got out of it you may leave the tree in
and do all the shopping maybe we ought
to think about the conflict of interest
now usually we get questions about
Christmas in november/december you're
asking one before the fourth of July you
totally threw me well because I've
wanted to ask you for a long time and
I'm just getting around to it all right
so your is your question about the
Christmas tree is it unbiblical or is
that where you're coming from well do
you think it really should be in the in
the church well let me just give you
some people have pointed to a verse in
Jeremiah 10 they think is that where it
is they think it talks about the
Christmas tree and I don't think that
verse is really talking about a
Christmas tree I think it's talking
about making an idol out of a tree and
carving and plating it the Christmas
tree tradition did not come from the
Bible it does come from some oh I think
it's Norwegian ceremonies where they
celebrate the trees and never lose their
leaves the conifers and the the pines
you know they would decorate them around
the winter solstice they'd say the Sun
was reborn because you get through the
shortest day of the year December 21 for
two days there's no change we just went
through that in June where you have the
summer solstice and the days got as long
as they would get around the 21st then
they stayed about the same for two or
three days and then they start getting
short again which makes me sad but
there's no nothing in the Bible that
says that you know we should worship a
Christmas tree I don't think there's a
moral problem if someone takes a
fragrant tree and puts it in their home
or their church but not if it's gonna
divide people we'll be back in just a
moment
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
we know we're here but we're not here
for very long so the most important
thing would be if we could learn during
this life how to live forever this is
the central focus of amazing facts I
think it's very important for us to
build churches but if the churches lose
the message of salvation they just
become buildings and shells I think it's
important to have a medical ministry and
build hospitals but if they separate
that from the message of salvation you
just prolong a sinners life for a little
while that's why for years amazing facts
has made it our focus to present the
saving truth that sets people free and
Friends we want to thank you for your
support in your gifts we'll do our very
best to convert those resources into the
currency of heaven may God bless you and
keep amazing facts in your prayers
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning and he'll be there until the
end discover the golden thread of a
savior woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry shadows of light seeing Jesus
in all the Bible get your copy today by
calling 855-578-6767 four seven once
again that's 800 eight three five six
seven four seven now let's join pastors
Doug Batchelor and Jean Ross for more
Bible answers live welcome back
listening friends to Bible answers live
and if you have a Bible question you can
give us a call that number 804 six three
seven two nine seven make it easy to
remember just eight hundred god says
use the Word of God one more time 800
for six three seven two nine seven and
my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross we have Noah listening in
Illinois no welcome to the program thank
you and my question is you know how
we're going to eat and have well we use
all the energy that we consume from the
food I roll we start the bathroom I've
wanted to know that since I joined the
church last year oh you know don't feel
bad for asking that question because
you'd be surprised how many people
wonder about that they think well
they're everything in heaven is perfect
then you know but the digestive system
of the creatures you know does that mean
there's gonna be anything impure well no
there's nothing impure in heaven but
think about it for a moment we eat what
comes from the trees and then the trees
eat that trees love manure what comes
from the creatures I just think that
it's gonna be different there so you got
to ask the question this way in the
Garden of Eden did Adam and Eve eat yes
did Adam and Eve have a natural
digestive system I highly suspect they
did probably there was just nothing foul
about it back then and that it was just
food for the trees so I think we're
gonna be surprised when we get to heaven
God designed people with a complete
digestive system I think we'll still
have that in heaven as will the animals
and it'll just be a perfectly pure cycle
of symbiotic relationships so yeah all
right well thank you for call no
appreciate if that helps we've got
Marjorie listening in Florida March
welcome to the program Marjorie in
Florida you on the air and your question
tonight yeah I have a quick question so
if someone was married only in court
without any pastors or anybody religious
to you know pray and bless the marriage
thus God recognized that marriage and if
they were to divorce
I'll both of them sweet well for other
things and infidelity
I'll both of them free to remarry so
it's kind of a hard question alright
first part of the question let's suppose
you're married in a court or by a
justice of the peace and it's a legal
marriage as far as the government is
concerned but does that mean that that
the marriage do they have to then get
married in that church
well no you don't have to if you're
believer it's always nice to be able to
share that celebration in a Christian
setting and consecrate your your vowels
in the presence of God in a in a
Christian way the Bible tells us that
one Isaac
met Rebecca says he took his wife he
took Rebecca she became his wife it was
I guess pretty simple back then so if
you're not married in in a church does
that give you more latitude to divorce I
would say no if you're legally married
you're legally married and the biblical
principles the qualifications for
divorce are the same the only grounds
for divorce for Christians is for
infidelity Jesus is saving for the cause
of fornication otherwise the person who
remarries is committing adultery if
you're marrying somebody that doesn't
have grounds you're committing adultery
with them that wouldn't change it
doesn't matter I don't think pastor also
I don't know what you think but I don't
think it matters if you're married in a
courthouse or you're married in a church
if you're married you're married if
you're a Christian it same policy
applies so I hope that helps a little
bit Marjorie is that answering your
question yes so that means you ought to
do everything in church if and if no one
prayed over I just give wonder whatever
you how they do with you yeah your if
you're legally married you're legally
married that's all a pastor will usually
ask he's not going to ask there may be
some churches that say well was it
sanctified in the church most pastors
just want to know are you legally
married and if you're illegally married
then you know it's always nice I know
some pastors that have done some
marriage renewal programs where couples
can come and renew their vows and a lot
of couples that they think well you know
we we ran off on elope we didn't have a
church wedding we'd like to do it in
presence of God and there's nothing
wrong with renewing your
having a marriage renewal certificate to
do it in the presence of God with prayer
so you could ask for that and you know
be a blessing probably next caller that
we have and oh by the way before we go
to the next caller we do have a book
called marriage divorce and remarriage
and I think anyone willing to learn more
about what the Bible says about marriage
will be happy to send this to you the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and just after the book on marriage
called marriage divorce and remarriage
we have Becky listening from Grand Ledge
Michigan Becky welcome to the program
all right how are you guys doing good
thank you for calling and your patience
your question I was doing a little Bible
study on first Corinthians chapter 1
verses 27 through 29 and I don't really
know I don't really understand it I'm
kind of stuck on well let me read this
for our friends that are listening in
1st Corinthians chapter 1 verse 27 I
think that's where it says but God has
chosen the foolish things of the world
to put to shame the wise and God has
chosen the weak things of the world to
put to shame the things that are mighty
and the base things of the world the
things that are despised God has chosen
God has chosen the things which are not
to bring to nothing the things that are
that no flesh should glory in his
presence so I think this is just Paul's
way of saying that God delights to use
humble means to do great things for
example Samuel comes to town to anoint a
king and they invite everybody but David
he's the young he's the weakest and
Samuel says no he's the one that God's
chosen God chose the weak things to kill
the giant God gives Samson the jawbone
of a donkey to defeat an army
he didn't give him a nuclear weapon God
often uses weak humble instruments the
Lord used Mary Magdalene to announce the
resurrection wasn't educated everybody
thought that she you know shouldn't be
at the party because she had a bad
reputation God uses the weak and the
despised things of the world to do great
things I think also even in a broader
sense paul is referencing the gospel how
jesus came he didn't come as a
conquering king he was
born in a manger and yet his work was so
profound it's so meaningful so God can
use simple things and do extraordinary
things and use simple people that are
committed to him
to do great things for his cause
absolutely does that help a little bit
Becky yeah but um personally I'm I think
maybe like the good Lord maybe he could
use disabled people you know to witness
to people you know could be a real help
absolutely there's a story in the Bible
where God actually he witnessed to the
Sanhedrin through a blind man that had
been healed and God used for lepers to
bring the good news of an abundance of
food to the whole nation of Israel so
God does he he even uses people who are
handicapped you can read the story about
Mephibosheth in the Bible who was
crippled in his feet and God used him
thank you very much Becky appreciate
your question
we've got Lou listening from New York
Lou welcome to the program hi thank you
for your ministry appreciate it thank
you I have an interesting question could
you kind of explain intelligent design
and how it compares to a person who
believes in biblical creation
yeah well biblical creation is
intelligent design intelligent design is
an argument for biblical creation or
Fiat creation it's because we see that
in the interworking systems that we
observe in nature these things could
never come about without an outside
super intelligence to develop these
inter working relationships for example
you know simple cells are so incredibly
complex when they first developed the
theory of evolution back in the days of
Darwin and Louis Pasteur when you look
through a primitive microscope and you
looked at a cell they were not very
powerful a cell looked like a little
gelatinous blob and they thought well
that might happen spontaneously but now
they look at that same cell through an
electron microscope
very powerful microscopes and they see
that a single cell of life has more
machinery and activity going on the New
York City at rush hour is extremely
complex and the idea of those inner
working machines and processes and
swimming and amino acids all lining up
in the spontaneously is impossible an
example of intelligent design would be
you know you might walk through the
desert and if you see you know the wind
and the rain has shaped the rocks to
look like you know a wheel are around or
beat a well that could be done through
the environment but if you're walking
through the desert and you see a
motorcycle up on a kickstand and it's
got the headlights and it's got the you
know the chain and the colored fenders
and a license plate you would never say
the wind and the rain did that because
the complexity of it and the way that it
functions in its environment means that
somewhere there's a motorcycle factory
and an intelligence made it when you
look at the organisms in the world they
are extremely more complex than a
motorcycle on its kickstand in the
desert and a lot of thinking scientists
now are just saying you know evolution
we just really can't support it anymore
or they say they believe in what they
call creation or what does it call the
evolution and creation yes yes think
evolution yeah that God somehow used
evolution but there had to be an
intelligence behind it because I mean
even the evolutionists are saying isn't
mother nature brilliant thank you you're
going oh it's not mother nature because
you know if you believe there's no god
there's no brilliance in accidents more
and more or believing either in creation
or evolution theory evolution because
they just see there has to be an
intelligence behind it so did that make
sense Lou yes it did thank you very much
appreciate a guy all right hey thanks
appreciate your question take care take
care by the way we do have a book called
win evolution flunked the science test
and we'll send you a free copy Lou the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and
again just ask for the book
when evolution flanked the science test
very interesting read next caller that
we have is calling from Houston from
Houston Texas you're on the line hey
Ryan yes I questioned about how you
thought and I want to say it might refer
to Corinthians to Stan but that to many
people you know they played in the skies
even Christians not realizing that the
Lord and His angels or was it here as we
speak on earth heaven earth collided
every day and there's no such thing as
coincidence
the supernatural signs they have to
announce you know everything that was in
the Bible still happen to this day on
earth but what about when you receive
the Holy Spirit sort of your eyes will
be opened to these things what's your
thoughts on that well I think when you
receive the Holy Spirit you may not
physically have your eyes open to see
angels in the spiritual world around us
but you certainly through reading the
word you become more sensitive to the
spiritual realities that we are not
wrestling with flesh and blood but
principalities and powers and high
places as Paul says in Ephesians chapter
yeah for a born-again Christian you can
feel that internal conflict all the time
we feel you know if you're a believer
you feel the war between the spirit and
the flesh and you're continually needing
to die to self as Paul said I die daily
take up our cross deny ourselves take up
our cross and follow Jesus you become
very aware that there is a spiritual
battle raging around every believer all
the time and we know by faith there are
good and evil angels involved in that
conflict right so that's what's wrong
with this world
though the angels and people don't
realize the good that's all you gotta do
is you know they can steer away don't
know bad angels ever see good ones right
and realize that you're angels and with
them it can help us yeah well and it's
absolutely true that you know through
prayer we can just invite God's angels
to guard us the Bible says the angel of
the lord encamps around those who fear
him and delivers them and he says in
Psalm 91 he will give his angels charge
over you to keep you in all of your ways
absolutely you know we pray for God's
Spirit and angels to protect us but yeah
there's good nae evil angels in this
world several times Jesus encountered
them as he was casting out Devils that's
what they are fallen angels all right
well thanks for your call Ryan how next
color that we have is epic ale listening
from Florida Abigail you on the air hi
hi in your question tonight the Bible
questions about Philippines for verse 13
I can do all things through Christ who
strengthens me and accident um it is it
like home
like is it physical you can do like
everything Oh or is it like faith and
spiritual well when Paul says I can do
all things through Christ who
strengthens me it doesn't mean that I
can pray and I'll necessarily have the
strength of Samson to lift up a thousand
pounds Paul is saying I can do all
things God wants me to do through Jesus
God will give you strength to faithfully
resist temptation to have the courage to
share your faith and to be an obedient
Christian he gives you the strength for
the things he's asked you to do and that
you can do all things that God asks you
to do through Christ so yeah it's not
saying you can leap off tall buildings
and flies faster than a speeding bullet
does that make sense Abigail yeah thank
you all right thank you so much for your
question
don't stay up too late you're in Florida
and it's past your bedtime if you enjoy
hearing solid biblical answers on Bible
answers live you can have those same
insights at your fingertips through the
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible the
updated hardcover version is available
at its lowest price ever and includes
the complete set of amazing facts 27
study guides plus a Bible numbers and
symbols charts and eight pages of
colorful maps this best-ever Bible gives
you a biblical cyclope dick index words
of Christ in red chronology of the old
estimate along with Doug bachelors how
to study the Bible feature and much more
call us at AF bookstore to learn more
about it at one eight hundred five
thirty eight seventy two seventy five
the amazing facts prophecy study Bible
stands apart from other Bible's giving
you the same solid answers you hear each
week on Bible answers live order your
copy today at AF bookstore calm or by
calling 1-800 five three eight seventy
two seventy five its caller that we have
is Nez listening from Arizona Nez are
you on the air somebody told me before
about no personal resurrection I want to
know where I can found that in the Bible
yeah alright we're gonna put you on
pause because we're getting a lot of
background noise where in the bible do
you find examples of the special
resurrection well a couple places minute
ago we read in Daniel 12 where it talked
about some will come forth from the
grave for shame and everlasting contempt
and I think you're gonna go to Matthew I
was gonna look at a revelation oh yeah
Matthew does time to that Revelation 1:7
says behold he is coming with clouds and
every eye will see him and they also
pierced him and all the tribes of the
earth will mourn because of him even so
amen so this is talking about the second
coming of Jesus talks about some who are
resurrected who played a leading role in
the crucifixion of Jesus I think in
particular what the high priest said
when he said I adjure thee about the
Most High speaking to Christ during his
trial
are you the Christ that's what Caiaphas
said and Jesus said you have said your
after you shall see the Son of man
coming with power and glory and so he's
resurrected to answer his question he
sees Jesus coming again
you know be a he's gonna get a front
seat witness that Christ is the Messiah
and it's gonna be terrifying so yeah
there there's a Mele the main three
verses there may be some others in the
Old Testament prophets that kind of
explained that some of those who were
the most culpable
and be trained and condemning Jesus are
going to be brought forth in a special
resurrection to see him coming glory
they had crowned him with a robe
a purple robe and beat him and a thorn
of crowns and they're gonna see him come
wearing the crown of the King of Kings
it's basically an act of justice all
right thanks you : is the next folder
that we have is calling from Sacramento
and I believe it's lament yeah you're on
the air and your name
it's Raymond Raymond we're getting
having a seminar here and you're a
question so the question was now that
Jesus is not physically on earth and
he's in heaven does he now know his time
of returning I believe so and I think
your question is related to the passage
where Jesus said no man knows the day or
the hour of his return the not even the
son but the father only and people said
wow Jesus is in the dark regarding the
time of his return the father won't tell
him no I just think at Christ on earth
in his in his humanity he didn't have
that information and just imagine for a
moment suppose he did have the date what
good would it be for him to have a date
October 22
you know 2020 what would 2020 mean to
the Apostles back then they didn't date
things that way you know Christ said I
don't know the day in the hour of Myra
coming in his humanity but now at the
right hand of the Father he is
omniscient meaning all-knowing I'm sure
he knows does that that make sense for
Raymond does it make sense
our world is going to now because I'll
be good to keep on going the way it's
grown without his return at some point
yeah absolutely it's like jesus said
unless those days be shortened no flesh
would be saved and I think we're at that
point now we do have a study guide we
can send you to talks about the the
ultimate deliverance coming yeah I'll be
happy to send that to you the number to
call is 883 five six seven four seven
after the study guide called the
ultimate deliverance and it's all about
the second coming of Christ
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 885 six seven four seven once again
that's 800 eight three five six seven
four seven
we've got Jonathan listening from
Colorado Jonathan welcome to the program
yeah hi hey thanks for calling
thanks I got a quick question what's
actually two questions by the same topic
so my first question is does the
desperation close for everyone at the
same time and I mean like now I imagine
once someone dies or probation closes
I'm talking about the end times right
physically before Christ us and also I
understood that the sign of the close of
probation is like a universal Sunday law
so what happens to the people that don't
know about that law does that mean that
they the probation I mean like so what's
the sign of close of probation in other
words all right a good question I
appreciate that now for our friends that
are listening when you use a phrase
close of probation it means there'll be
a time in the world's history where
wildlife may go on on the planet the
Savior saved in the lost or loss and I
think pastor Ross that's in revelation
22 and Jesus is he that's holy let him
be holy still
I'll let you look that up another
example of that would be back in the
days of Noah God told Noah in his family
to get on the door get on the ark Noah
probably stood in the door and appealed
to people to come and nobody came then
it says God shut the door well life went
on outside the ark for seven more days
but the door was shut even though life
went on the saved were sealed inside the
loss were lost at verse 2 referring to
his revelation chapter 22 verse 12
let me read verse 11 it says actually as
first 11 is the one you're thinking
about he that is unjust let him be
unjust still he that is filthy let him
be filthy still he that is righteous let
him be righteous still he that is holy
let him be holy still and behold I am
coming quickly and my reward is with me
to give to every man according to his
work so this occurs just before Jesus
comes
yeah now why would Jesus ever say let
the filthy be filthy still he always
wants to cleanse him unless there's no
more hope for the cleansing they've gone
too far so most scholars believe and
there's no verse that says on
such-and-such a date but most scholars
believe that when the beast power
finally issues the death decree it'll
show that everybody has either received
the mark of the beast or the seal of God
and the die is forever cast and that
will be the the death decree for not
worshiping the image of the Beast and
receiving its mark will be the pivotal
event I think and that of course is
Revelation chapter 13 that talks about
the mark of the beast we do have a study
guide that deals with the subject called
the mark of the beast and we'll be happy
to send it out to anyone dealing with
Revelation chapter 13 all you'll need to
do is call the number is 883 five six
seven four seven after the study guide
entitled the mark of the beast again the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
next follow that we have is khari or
kerry listening from missouri yes hi
welcome how are you guys doing tonight
always better than we deserve couple
minutes for your question so let's get
right to it okay Mike my question is
about the Sabbath I'm a little confused
I understand the Sabbath the holy day
the commandment what constitutes the
Sabbath being on a Saturday versus
Sunday and will the people that worship
on a Sunday or another day are they
going to be condemned for that well let
me first answer that question there's
gonna be millions of people in heaven
that maybe didn't understand which day
was the seventh day there will be people
in heaven that had too many wives and I
know this is gonna probably get some
hate mail but biblically there'll be
people in heaven that even own slaves
even though that's got not God's will
because they didn't know better God
winked at their ignorance as it says
whereas it acts 17:30 I think at the
times of this ignorance God winked at
sin is knowing to do good and not doing
it so when someone learns a biblical
truth whether
that truth is on that you should only
have one wife and you shouldn't have any
slaves or what day the Sabbath is then
we're responsible to follow the light
that God gives us when we know so to
answer that question of course there's
gonna be people in heaven that maybe
didn't understand things but they live
it up to the light that they had but if
you're gonna go by the Bible there's no
question that the seventh day of the
week you just look in a dictionary look
on a normal calendar it's Saturday and
that's why the Jewish nation still
celebrates the Sabbath on the seventh
day of the week Moslems do it on the
sixth day which is Friday Christians do
it on the first day the day of the
resurrection which is Sunday but there
is no command in the Bible to change the
Sabbath from the seventh to the first
day and so this is where a lot of the
confusion comes in hey friends there's a
lot more I could share about that I
appreciate your question go to this
website Sabbath truths calm that's where
you're gonna find it sabbath truth calm
god bless you friends if you've been
blessed by the program go to amazing
facts and help us stay on the air talk
to you next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
in six days God created the heavens and
the earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth calm what if
you could know the future what would you
do what would you change to see the
future you must understand the past
Alexander the Great becomes King when
he's only 18 but he's a military prodigy
a hundred and fifty years in advance
Cyrus had been named Rahm was violent
they were ruthless they were determined
the Gospel writers see his death as a
fulfillment of salvation this intriguing
documentary hosted by pastor Doug
Batchelor explores the most striking
Bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time get your copy
today available now on DVD blu-ray or
USB for more information visit kingdoms
in time.com journey back through time to
the center of the universe discover how
a perfect angel transformed into Satan
the arts villain
[Music]
the birth of evil a rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF ag0 RG and sign
up for our free Bible study course and
make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at